so Dave we're here at collector mania
today tell me what you've been enjoying
about the event it is good meeting the
fans and seeing how excited they're
about the Harry Potter franchise getting
pictures taken and also just seemed like
nice normal friendly people what's been
the big question everyone asked you
today
well the main one I do tend to get is
how long does it take to get into the
makeup yeah and I'm just really
realizing that the makeup took two half
hours but it took someone a week to
prepare the prosthetic because really
was a prosthetic that was put on rather
than makeup being applied so that's the
main question how does it feel when
you're in something like that though for
Harry Potter does it I mean is it
uncomfortable Antony no in fact the
other thing was I'd forget I was wearing
a prosthetic and it like a fierce
werewolf and I just start talking to
people normally and way you look at me
like that and then there's only like I'm
just up like a werewolf yeah so that was
old now they did a really good job that
the crew there were nick diamonds team
were fantastic so I didn't realize I was
wearing that whole Harry Potter world
cuz obviously there's a huge and is
still a huge phenomenon isn't it I think
the way I was treated when I you know
walked on set I was in the sixth film so
they were ready everything was
established but they just treat you like
you know you're one of the family
immediately it's usually the people
you're working with that make it show
good and there was such yo kind you know
big stars in Helena bonham-carter to
Michael Gambon and in Rickman the first
day I was on set with those guys and
they're just so hi Dave how are you and
yeah so that was very enjoyable what
it's like working with those guys what
are they like as actors and as people to
work with just just friendly and and
they've got the confidence you know not
to take it overly seriously where maybe
Alan Rickman does but
yeah not overly seriously enjoy it and
then and we're just making films we're
not going to war now we're not laying
bricks it's quite a cool easy job and
they enjoy the process and as soon as
the camera stopped rolling everyone's
you have cracking jokes and having fun
what was David Yates like to work with
he was like like a big happy child
great very excited child you know too
full of enthusiasm and yeah obviously
very bright with a child's imagination
which we need to get the story across
young and why do you think it's been so
successful over the years very positive
cuz people are still loving it now
aren't they all the movies and the book
it's almost become part of history now I
remember my daughter reading the books
and and it you know that was a you know
a big you know a big phenomena and then
it went on so it's like you know I can
remember all those years ago where my
dog was reading them then going to
becoming part of it
afterwards you know I've got a little
part in the film so but for everyone
it's just and it's so British so even
when it came out the stories that they
reflect back on stories that we've heard
before from our childhoods and and
probably our parents daughters as well
there's you know it's timeless and
ageless you know deliberately concocted
like that by JK Rowling you mentioned
you daughter there and she was a fan of
the books as well what did she think
when you got a role and yeah in the one
of the films and three of the films well
she kind of downplayed it I think a
friend seemed more excited and even when
I invited her to the premiere of the
half-blood Prince I said Oh John ago and
she's like oh maybe when every other
woman I knew in the world was calling me
out Jane can I come can I come can I go
so she plays it yeah pretty cool but you
know I think she appreciates that I've
got a nice house now let's talk a little
bit about another one of the films
you've made snatch tell me what that was
like yeah it was like it's so long ago
and it's a film I get most recognized
from so that that was like you know when
it whenever but now I know you from
somewhere it's so often you snatch and
it was my first film where I'm like I
didn't see you know yeah I've done that
25 films and you see all these and like
oh yeah but they remember in flat which
shows like at the time I didn't know
what a great film it was going to be you
know how long long lasting it would be
so that's a surprise with things like
working with those guys cuz I was seeing
everyone saying well-known in snatch
aren't they well they are now but at
that point they weren't and Brad Pitt
was young when I said oh hi I'm John
David went oh hi I'm Brad Oh your bread
you know as if I wasn't gonna recognize
him you know he was really down to earth
Jason Statham was you know it was really
good you say you've been in a lot so
like you say people recognize he'd
snatch they don't realize all the other
films as well what should they thought
the ones have been your favorite ones to
me
I think command performance was Dolph
Lundgren that that was a good film you
know not really a mainstream film but
for me it was like a lead role with
Dolph it was an iconic figure I have a
fight with them at the end of the film
which is like oh my god I'm fighting
Ivan Drago it's great
and and and and the fact that it was my
that they needed something to do a
Russian accent and Eric Roberts was was
books but he wouldn't he couldn't do the
accent I wouldn't do the accent I chose
not to do the accent so I got rush in
there the end so it's quite substantial
shoot with them and it's more intense
it's always Shakespearean I know it's
like adult flown back but my characters
like Shakespeare you know he was
desperate and desolate and and just
really wanted suicide that you know and
that's not a fun role to play but you
know I put that rather than just being
the scream and shout in action hero I
was or action villain I was I was a
desperate yeah how do you approach your
role like that when you come up sense
it's all it's all ER to me it's all just
inside quite an emotional person so all
those feelings of anger desperation
despair you know lust everything is in
me at some point it's a great degree so
I just channel whatever is needed and it
comes fairly immediately and hopefully
it comes across as real genuine in what
wisdom Dolph Lundgren like to work with
I mean what was it like doing that fight
feeling oh he's great you know he's a
big strong athletic man a little taller
than I am but probably not quite as
heavy and and it's very open very open
and it's not a dictator in it by any
means you know he's open to different
suggestions and cuz I was professional
fighter as well so he wanted to hear
what what I would actually do in the
fight what would you do yeah
yeah so that brought some reality into
it what do you do action scenes like
that you have you have to be quite
colorful because you can't get you know
injured made it yeah there's a
difference you know professional fight
you've just got to miss them and make
them look good you know and yeah there
is that danger but but unless you're an
idiot you you do manage to yeah you do
manage to like we are now hours I'm
gonna hit him ah my god yeah that's a
pun true is it Chris Hemsworth
and a punch him in the chest in in a
snow white and yeah he's a big strong
tough guy but I suppose like you know I
should have pulled the punch a little
bit more because I thought it's only in
his chest
that I can give him a little one but
yeah I think I think yeah not the wind
out then but we had some great fights
meet me and Chris we had some good fun
rolling around in in sudden damage him
so you can employ that you can employ me
again I won't anyone like and the fight
scenes as well that was a lot of fun and
I chose to do a Scottish accent similar
to Chris's because I thought there was
more of a storyline to our character
that then was revealed in the film so so
I said to Chris listen he sounds like me
and you we go back a long way so let me
I'm going to be Scottish as well so it's
I was glad to be allowed to you know put
the accent in there and the fight scenes
were great one was cut out
because it because now it says to
condense it a little bit and that was
probably the better fight yeah but it
was it was better because it was done
messy
there was a look on choreograph I
thought we were scrambling and
scrambling and grabbing each other and
he was fighting me and I was tripping
him and so it's like a mess as a real
fight would be you know you in a real
fight you don't give each other the
space to perform the moves that you see
in the movies you will fight you're
probably right on top of someone and
there's a lot more grappling involved so
it was good to just to work with Chris
and to beat up Thor there's great I'm
surprised Fenrir Greyback versus Thor
Fenrir wins having saw two as well this
year aren't we I thought you know this
great you know he looks great and the
films he does a really quality yeah and
he's just a regular kinda nice guy and
he appreciates everything that we've
been given to him in his
she's right yeah I like like Christian
and snow-white in the headsman a second
one coming we believe as well yeah I
think I might be dead I'm not sure but
I'm not certainly I'm not I mean I don't
know who's directing it because there's
that issue as well as there was
directing it because because I've gotten
very well with Rupert Sanders and and he
liked the stuff I was doing but so I
think I might just be wounded and maybe
I could come back come back for the next
one
yeah with with an axe in my back because
I'm not you know what you don't see on
camera you know anything could happen
goodness absolutely would you like to
say to your fans you've seen you'd all
these tools out there Dave well just
keep on watching and hopefully there's
you know bigger and better things to
come in the future and turn up at
exhibitions like this and so show your
support and what's next for you I've
just done a pilot actually with Charles
dance we're trying to get my beth off
the ground you know a film you imagine
new technology but but classic as it
should be yeah not putting nineteen
thirty's Argentina anywhere it's like
you know in the Scottish Highlands yo so
I've just done that and another pilot
for a comedy series and then just
looking to get some individual projects
off the ground my pleasure
you